An election
where there's
no polling, there's only one frontrunner,
but where it all could come unglued
for that frontrunner
of just a handful of votes
go the other way.
In a nutshell is House
Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy existence right now?
He wants to be desperately the next House
speaker in the upcoming
new Republican controlled House.
But because his new majority is so slim,
as you know, he's
got to keep as many hardliners
as possible from voting no.
As some have already vowed to do.
So he's also got to keep
moderates on board
and not end up a hostage to the extreme
supporters of the former president
if he actually gets the job,
but also not Eliot them
completely, which might explain
some of his recent verbal contortions,
such as condemning the former
president's dinner
with anti-Semite
but without actually
condemning the host by name.
I don't
think anybody should
be spending any time
with Nick Fletcher's.
He has no place in this Republican Party.
I think President Trump
came out four times and condemned him
and didn't know who he was.
Just as a point of fact,
the former president has never condemned
that person, let alone four times
in any event.
Congressman McCarthy's
zigzagging is not exactly new.
Here he is shortly
after the January six attack on Congress
The president bears responsibility
for Wednesday's
attack on Congress by mob rioters.
He should have immediately
denounced the mob
when he saw what was unfolding.
These facts require immediate action
by President Trump.
I was just days
after the insurrection, famously
not long after
he was back in Mar
a Lago
currying favor with his supporters.
Since Entourage
joins us now with more on his belt
latest balancing act.
So as of tonight,
how does McCarthy's
path to the speakership?
How does it look like he'll get there?
It's really uncertain
at this point, Anderson.
And this is precisely the concern
that McCarthy and his allies
had in the run up to the midterms.
They spent a ton of money
to try to build
what they call the governing majority.
They wanted to.
30 seats,
235 seats, maybe even 240 seats.
They got probably
were looking at 222 seats.
And that means to get become
elected speaker,
he'd have 218 votes on January 3rd.
So if for more than four Republicans
vote against him, vote
for another candidate,
that means he will have a problem.
And right now
there are about five Republicans
hardliners who are signaling
they will either are either nosed
or that they're very likely
to vote against him,
meaning that McCarthy at
the moment has a math problem.
Now talking to some of those hardliners,
they tell me that there's more than five.
They say there could be 20.
They're even larger number than that.
And some of them,
like Congressman Bob
Good of Virginia, told me
he is urging more to come out
publicly and make clear
that McCarthy does not have the votes
say they are opposed.
And at that point,
he says that there will be another
candidate who will emerge
There's a
quality candidates
who represent the conservative center
of the Republican conference
who are privately acknowledging that once
it becomes
clear it's not going to Kevin McCarthy,
they are interested in becoming speaker,
but they're not going to raise their hand
publicly until it's clear to them
that it's not going to be Kevin McCarthy.
Are you one of these private
no votes
that McCarthy is not coming up publicly
to say so?
That my position is pretty clear on this
is that no one is telling sort of 18.
And the whole point here
is to have a conversation.
Now, I'm not talking about
how I'm going to vote or not vote
what I'm talking about is
my constituents
sent me here to end the status quo.
So, Chip Roy, that
last congressman is
what gives McCarthy and his allies
some hope.
They believe they can win over
some of those detractors of critics
by negotiating with them.
And McCarthy
did get a boost from more mainstream
Republicans earlier today.
The letter was sent from 21 Republicans
warning about dire consequences
with a massive floor
fight on the first day
of the new Congress,
saying in the letter,
make no mistake,
we will not allow this conference
to be dragged down a path
to a paralyzed house
that weakens our hard fought majority,
showing real signs of tension
even before they take the majority
next year Anderson.
I mean,
is there anyone who could actually make
a run at the speakership
if he doesn't get the 218 votes?
That's also unclear.
What we have learned
is that Republicans in this hard
line group
have reached out
to some of McCarthy's own top deputies,
including Steve Scalise,
the number two Republican,
and also Tom Emmer,
who is going to be the number
three Republican
in the new Congress,
as well as Jim
Jordan is expected to be the House
Judiciary Committee chairman.
They asked all of them
to jump into this race.
We were told that all of them said
no, that they are backing McCarthy.
Now, the hope among these
these
the McCarthy detractors,
is that once it is abundantly clear
he cannot become elected speaker,
somebody else could jump into this race.
Perhaps one of those three At the moment,
they're not signaling
they will do just that.
But, Anderson,
this is such a rare scenario
that we are talking about.
If he cannot get 218 votes,
McCarthy on January 3rd,
then we'll go to a second ballot
of voting
and third ballot of voting potentially
even beyond. It's been 100 years.
1923 was the last time
there have been more than one ballot
to elect House Speaker as possible.
That could happen again.
Now on with Roger.
Thanks so much. Appreciate it.